First, he's a third-term
US rep from Texas's 16th,
who's the Democratic nominee
for Senate against Ted Cruz,
Congressman Beto O'Rourke.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
BILL: Hey!
How are you sir?
Nice to meet you.
Wow. Glad to have you.
Okay. Well, wow, that's--
Look at that. They, uh...
Did you...
Did you stack the audience here
with people--
-No? Well they--
-No.
They seem to know who you are
already.
It's like when the Beatles
came to America.
They didn't know
everybody would know them.
Uh, so, for--
Well, we're just learning
a lot of people,
so first of all,
explain the name.
So, born Robert Francis O'Rourke
in El Paso Texas,
fourth generation.
But like almost anyone born
Robert in El Paso,
-called Beto from day one.
-BILL: I see.
It's a nickname for Beto,
or, uh, for Robert or Alberto
-or any name ending in -berto.
-BILL: You're full Irish?
Um, pretty Irish.
Uh, especially tomorrow.
-Yeah. (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHTER)
Okay. And you're running
against Ted Cruz.
Okay-- Yes. Okay. So...
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
Ted Cruz, we know,
is very disliked.
Let me read some quotes.
Uh, Al Franken said:
"Like Ted-- I like Ted Cruz
more than most of my
other colleagues
like Ted Cruz,
and I hate Ted Cruz.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHTER)
Bob Dole in 2015 said,
"There are a lot
of good candidates.
I like nearly all of them,
except Cruz."
BETO: Right. (LAUGHS)
John Boehner:
"Lucifer in the flesh.
Never worked with
a more miserable son of a bitch
in my life."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHTER)
Lindsey Graham:
"If you killed Ted Cruz
on the floor of the Senate
nobody would convict you."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHTER)
-Uh, I just...
My quest-- (CHUCKLES)
My question is,
how bad are you gonna feel
if you lose to that guy?
Yeah. Yeah. I-- I'll tell ya.
There's something though
happening in Texas right now.
I've traveled to 226
of the 254 counties.
-BILL: Wow.
-People are so fired up,
regardless of party
or geography.
So it's Democrats coming out
for sure.
But it's also Republicans
and Independents.
It's in the really big cities.
It's in the real small towns.
The places that no-one
has ever visited,
including Ted Cruz,
because for the first four years
he was in the Senate,
he was actually in Iowa,
and New Hampshire
and South Carolina and Nevada.
He visited all 99 counties
-of Iowa.
-BILL: Of Iowa, right.
Uh, and so there are places
where they haven't seen
a US senator,
and so when we show up,
hold a town-hall meeting,
listen to the people
that we wanna serve
and represent, we're really
making a connection.
And folks
are committing themselves
to the work ahead,
and I think we've got a great
shot at winning in November.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
Well, we, uh...
We've heard that before
about elections.
-I mean, we--
-Yeah, absolutely.
I always wonder why Texas
and California,
have very similar
Latino demographics.
I think the eligible Latino
voting number here
in California is 28 percent.
Same as Texas.
Why are we so Blue
and Texas is not Blue?
It's only 43 percent white now,
Texas. Is that right?
That's right.
Texas is one of the most
gerrymandered states
in the union.
It is also a non-voting state.
And those two things
are connected.
-There are some people--
-BILL: Non-voting?
That's right. We're 49th
in the country in voter turnout.
The courts four times alone
last year found that
our gerrymandering is in part
based on race and ethnicity.
There are some people
who are not supposed to vote.
There are some people's voices
that are not supposed
to be heard.
It's on us to run a campaign
that brings in everyone,
from every community,
every community
within every community,
into this campaign.
To make sure that they're heard,
and that they're actually
leading what we're doing.
I think when we do that,
we're gonna give people
a reason to vote.
And we saw the greatest
Democratic primary
midterm Senate turnout
last Tuesday, in 36 years.
-Uh, we saw-- Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUSE)
-So, votes are--
-The Republicans came out
in Texas too,
-in bigger numbers.
-They sure did. Y'know what?
We don't have-- This is not
in the bag by any means.
Not at all. And you know what?
That's a great thing,
because folks from both parties,
Independents as well,
are getting off the sidelines
and into the game.
But they recognize
that this year,
everything that they care about,
um,
everything that they've told
their kids about this country,
is on the line.
And for Amy and me,
that's what motivated us.
We anticipate the question
our kids,
Ulysses and Molly and Henry,
are gonna ask us:
"When you had the chance
to do something in 2018
when they were talking
about walls and Muslim bans
and the press
as the enemy of the people,
what did you guys do?"
And we're gonna tell them that
we and the 28-million of Texas
helped this country
get back on track
and on the right direction, so--
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
-Um, I feel lucky
to be a part of it.
BILL: Um...
And you-- And you don't--
And you don't take PAC money?
I don't take a dime
of PAC money.
No corporations.
No special interests.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
BILL: For those, uh...
For anyone who's watching
and might not be
a political junkie,
what is PAC money?
-What does that mean, PAC?
-So, political action committees
um, represent the corporations
and interests
that have business
before Congress.
So, uh, the pharmaceutical
industries,
the telecom industries,
the energy industries,
um, the insurance industries.
And they give money
to members of Congress,
not just for access,
although that's part of it.
Um, they're also buying outcomes
and actual legislative language
that appears in the bills
and the bills that become laws.
When you wonder why
Congress is so dysfunctional,
why it doesn't represent
the interests
of the people it purports
to serve,
it's because it's so tied
to the sources of money
that are coming in,
and it's those corporations.
It's why pharmaceutical prices
continue to rise.
It's why, uh,
we're the least insured country
in the developed world.
It's why we're missing out
on so many great opportunities
to do the big, important,
ambitious work before us.
And for Democrats especially,
it's not enough to decry
Citizens United,
and say that all this big money
sloshing through the halls
of Congress is bad.
We've got to start
walking the talk.
So in this campaign,
we have out-raised Ted Cruz
by well more than
a million dollars
without taking a dime from PACs.
-All people. Human beings.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
But don't forget
he's a giant asshole.
That-- That's true.
Vote so we'll never have
to wonder
-who it is I represent...
-BILL: Right.
...or who I'm voting for.
It's gonna be the people
of Texas every single time.
So, what-- What would you say
are your top three?
If you had to say your top three
most important issues
facing this country.
-Yeah.
-What are yours?
Too many people can't find a job
or are in a job right now
that does not pay a living wage.
And they need the dignity
and the function and purpose
-that comes with work.
-BILL: Number one is jobs.
Number two: If you're not
healthy enough to go to that job
or finish your education
or raise your family,
you're not doing yourself
any good.
You're not doing the rest of us
So, universal healthcare.
The ability for everyone
-to see a doctor, regardless...
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
of income.
So you're for... single-payer?
If that's how we get there,
uh, that's how we get there.
-I'm-- I'm open to--
-Whoa, that's a big "if,"
Congressman.
"If that's how we get there."
That's a big issue to go,
"Well, if--"
Listen, I-- I think Medicare
works really well.
Its overhead cost
is two percent.
You compare that against
private insurance companies,
sixteen, seventeen percent.
It's effective, it's efficient.
I think that's a great model.
So you're where Bernie Sanders
is with healthcare?
Yeah, I think he's got
a good plan,
and I would support his bill
in the Senate.
-(AUDIENCE MEMBER WHISTLES)
-I think--
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
Uh... And I'll tell you...
I'll tell you another issue
where Texas
I think, is uniquely positioned
to lead.
We are the most diverse state
in the country.
I'd like to think we are the
defining immigrant experience.
The city I represent,
El Paso, Texas,
is one of, if not the,
safest cities in America.
And a quarter of those
that I represent
were born in another country.
They chose us.
They're making us stronger,
safer, more secure.
We should be the ones
leading the fight
for immigration reform,
rewriting immigration law
in our own image,
from our own traditions
and values and interests.
Um, Ted Cruz was
the sole senator
out of 98 who showed up
to work that day a month ago,
the sole senator to vote no
on just proceeding
on debate and discussion
to be able to protect Dreamers
and allow those
more than one-million
of our fellow Americans
to contribute to their
full potential,
to the success of this country.
We need a senator
who leads on those issues.
-BILL: Okay, so--
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
So jobs is your one,
healthcare is your two.
-What was your three?
-Immigration.
Immigration. Wow.
So Russia, the environment,
they don't make the top three.
Russia and the environment
are really important.
-I mean, here's another--
-BILL: Four, five?
-Yeah. There you go.
-(GROANS)
Here's one where Texas
can lead. Listen.
You know us as an energy state,
right? And we're proud of that.
Lot of good jobs
in the oil and gas industry,
the refining industry.
But we're also leading
the country right now
in the generation of wind power.
We will soon lead the country
in the generation
of solar power.
There are more clean energy jobs
in the state of Texas today
than there are carbon energy
jobs in the state of Texas.
And it's not even close.
So whether it is
saving the planet for
the generations that follow us,
recognizing that maybe
man-made climate change
didn't cause Harvey,
but man-made climate change
will ensure
that there are more Harveys,
that they are more frequent,
they are more intense,
there are more droughts
in the Panhandle.
We have less opportunities
to grow our own food
and pass this planet on
to the next generation.
Whether it's jobs,
whether it's economic growth,
for all the right reasons
in the world,
Texas can and should lead
on environmental issues
for this country.
-And-- And, uh...
-(APPLAUSE)
And what about, uh, weed?
I ask for a friend.
-BETO: Yeah. (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHTER)
Um...
No, but-- but-- I mean--
Like, I love Texas.
I-- Texas knows how to party.
I've gone there as a guest.
Y'know, as a comedian,
for, like, 35 years.
-You've come to El Paso.
-Many times. I love El Paso.
San Antonio, Austin, Dallas,
Houston.
They're all great cities.
They're all fun places.
And they love their weed.
Uh...
California finally
took the plunge.
Texas seems like
the kind of place
where it's a tough--
tough road to hoe there.
Where are you on that one?
I've joined a bill,
written by
a Republican colleague,
former prosecutor
who waged the war on drugs,
saw how futile it was
from the front lines,
to end the federal prohibition
on marijuana.
-(APPLAUSE)
-Um...
So legal in Texas
is where we're going?
It should be.
-And we should control
and regulate its sale and...
-Yes.
-Uh, listen. We--
-It unites people.
-We have the world's--
-Right? No, no.
They smoke it in the city,
they smoke it in the country,
the hippies smoke it,
the rednecks smoke it.
It's-- It's--
It is a uniting thing.
-And--
-I'll show you after the show.
No, I'm cool.
So, we get a chance
to do the right thing.
We have the world's largest
prison population bar none.
We have folks who are
wasting away behind bars...
-BILL: Yes.
-...who need to be
raising families,
uh, working, paying taxes,
starting jobs,
touring in punk rock bands,
writing novels...
-Whatever they're supposed to do
in life...
-BILL: Right. (LAUGHS)
...let's allow them to do that,
not lock 'em up.
All right. I'll be rooting
for ya, and I know they will.
-All right, thank you...
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
BILL: Thank you very much.